it's like some Americans you're headed
to the apple orchard this autumn you
might want to know about the popularity
of what you're picking after more than
half a century of being America's
favorite Apple the long reign of the Red
Delicious has ended and for many it's
fall has been a long time coming
Don Dahler of course introduces us to
the new apple of America's eye at
Fishkill farms in upstate New York their
annual fall harvest of apples is in full
swing but this year there's a new king
of the orchard being crowned the gala
Apple is projected to come in at number
one by the end of 2018 surpassing the
reigning champion Red Delicious do you
look forward to this time of year or do
you kind of dread it a little both I
asked third-generation farmer Josh
Morgenthau if he's seen a shift away
from Red Delicious since taking over his
family's orchard in 2008
yeah we've pulled out some of our Red
Delicious trees we have seen the last
few years
part of our crop go on picked we're
definitely downsizing Red Delicious and
implanting other varieties that we think
have more potential is it just that our
palates have gotten more sophisticated
do you think gosh that's a tough a tough
question I think maybe our palates have
gotten more sophisticated but also for
so many years the Red Delicious and it's
about color and shape and and red
represents ripeness and so what looked
good on a shelf is what people would buy
created in the late 1800s in Iowa the
introduction of the Red Delicious apple
redefined a whole category of fruit
author and Apple historian Roman
Jakobson I don't think we'll ever see an
Apple as iconic as the Red Delicious
again but I think it's probably a good
thing think if you think about it Red
Delicious was the icon of kind of like a
1950's America which was very homogenous
by the 1980s Red Delicious was
completely dominant maybe 75% of the
market
growers back then believed that
Americans would never buy an apple that
wasn't all one color so either red
golden or green then New Zealand started
growing an apple called the gala the
gala not only looked different but
tasted different the fruit was really
sweet and had a crispy texture to munch
on once Americans took a bite there was
no going back that did not exist in any
of the American apples and it very
quickly became an increasingly popular
Apple to the point that as of this year
it has finally surpassed Red Delicious
to become the number one apple really at
this point Red Delicious is last market
is export so basically what's happening
is US consumers have caught on to the
fact that it tastes terrible but they're
still part of the world that haven't
figured that out yet
un dis variety is it good as the
American consumer began rediscovering
the Apple the demand for taste trumped
appearance and the Apple industry had to
find a way to adapt every time an apple
grower has to learn how to to grow a new
Apple it's a challenge so they all have
their own idiosyncrasies Cornell
University horticulture professor
Gregory Peck the majority of apples are
bred through conventional means and it
might take anywhere from 3 to 7 years
before that seedling produces apples and
it can be evaluated so right there it's
a very long process a long process that
has created over 7,000 varieties of
apples being grown today making the core
competition that much tougher
I don't think galas reign will be very
long it just passed Red Delicious after
really decades of slowly climbing but
there's another Apple on the block
that's kind of like the third wave of
apples skyrocketing out of fifth place
is the Apple expected to dethrone Gala
within the next ten years the Honey
Crisp is definitely taken center stage
and changed the industry consumers are
willing to pay $3 a pound and not you
know 99 cents or dollar fifty
and that has really I think changed the
industry in a major way and opened the
doors for other varieties that taste
better and you know supermarkets and
distributors are realizing people will
pay for a better better Apple for CBS
this morning Saturday Don Dahler
Hopewell Junction New York he actually
took down the Red Delicious he did yeah
7,000 varieties of Apple I know that
blew me away
I had no idea it was like three in an
apple pie I thought it was crazy yes
there was a Red Delicious on the down
heading down and this guy he kicked them